almost rain Salu is with me foreign
minister of Estonia thank you very much
for taking your time this morning you
applauded Germany for delivering the air
defense system irst to Ukraine has
Germany woken up
uh no in a comprehensive manner Western
Community has not done enough
and this price is paid by Blood of
ukrainians and my message is clear we
are not out of stockpiles concerning the
heavy Weaponry Ukrainian friends have
asked and also a munition and Russia is
now intentionally distracting civilian
infrastructure before the winter fall
and to give a particular air defense in
a large sense
to Ukraine we need to act to avoid this
Guernica taking place and therefore I
upload a brave step of Germany and it is
also a good sign that when German
Chancellor declared it already after
some days it was delivered
to the Ukraine and so my message is that
we should rise our
altitude immediately immediately
now the Baltic states have from the
start essentially criticized Germany for
not doing enough to support Ukraine
militarily your country Estonia has
given about 10 times as much Aid per
head of population as Germany has
despite being less than half as Rich
what do you think about that
I think that
there is behind our argument why we are
doing that is a a reason and heart the
heart is indeed a moral sentiment that
Ukrainian civilians Ukraine and people
needs to be defended and this is a in
the current context it's the only way
the most effective way to do that and
the second element is also to from the
reason to understand that to do more
quit more quickly is
the
most direct way to end more in a more
Speedy manner this war because now if we
look how the Western Community has acted
it has basically been in a way proactive
like when the Putin has done something
then as a response there has been a
certain new level of arms delivery a new
level of sanctions my goal is to change
that Paradigm that we will as we we will
indeed by our hearts and practical
deliverables invest to Ukrainian Victory
and therefore it means not uh
it has not you know in a sense to do
what Putin in particular steps is doing
but just giving enough
um arms and Rising the level altitude of
sanction to the such painful level that
this would end the war that the heat
will rise to the Putin to such
temperature but unfortunately hasn't
been the case yet
now Germany's foreign minister so your
counterpart has said that whenever she
travels to the Baltic states or to
Poland she keeps hearing this one
question can we trust Germany foreign
minister do you trust Germany
yes I think the I paraphrased also that
question today in the conference
underlying aberbrook's
question surely We Trust Germany and
speaking about our Airlines defense
posture and what is Germany doing as a
framework nation of NATO in Lithuania
which were very practical deliverables
and I applaud to that but the question
is now a more extension
can Ukraine trust uh West this is a
question and the the response
is still uh on the way to to to deliver
because
in that context
we have capabilities to act more and it
depends on our determination and
willpower Putin has put all in
escalative steps now made in recent time
and we should also
show our determination by ramping up the
price of this aggression
now MPS in your country have voted to
label Russia a terrorist state
what does that imply I mean how can this
change also Ukraine's perception of what
the West is doing when you change the
narrative when you change the wording
it's very important I think because
in the beginning there was a word quote
to quote script and so to take also I
think that this attribution of the what
is going on is of the most important
basis also to to
commit actions
Estonia was the first country on Earth
also to declare this war as a genocidal
War I I drafted it the text I spoke many
international law experts I spoke with
Representatives victims and so my my
message is clear that this uh Putin
intent is to annihilate One Nation so
this is a central intent and all these
actions have showed that basically they
can all these actions in this genocidal
work can describe uh by the articles of
genocidal convention against Kennesaw so
and also
some
some parties or actors also in the west
have avoided this description because
why they are avoiding they are saying
that it could escalate and truly this
convention last paragraph of convention
states that if the state's parties will
find a genocide taking place they have
to
tackle it and somebody says it might
lead to the escalation
but my answer is what does it mean it
might lead it might escalate
in the kennestite is taking place
this is a case of not even about
Ukrainian War about these
particular people who are dying but this
is a case study a question mark about
our Humanity about who we are the
current generations of Europeans who so
proudly State and speak about their
values now is a question or who we
actually really are and
we might be courageous that our I don't
know grandchildren look back to on us
How brave we are or we could also
morally fail and it would be illiterally
then shameful to look to the mirror
maybe maybe after some time
now you've also been calling for the
creation of an international Tribunal
for crimes against aggression
just so that Vladimir Putin and his
allies would be held accountable what is
missing from the current justice system
so what role would this new tribunal
have
well the current are a criminal
responsibility system international
under the competence of ICC doesn't
cover particularly this in a way mother
of crimes against humanity this
basically organizing the war pushing the
button and like a supreme leader declare
like
organizing the war of aggression
actually which afterwards all these
atrocities are executed and so therefore
if we look to the past
the solution has been establishment of
particular uh legal Partners tribunals
our talk in the case
which could also address these crimes
a particular crime of aggression
committed by Putin at his either
uniformed or not near top leadership
accomplished
what role could Germany play in this
context and do you what what how do you
perceive this difference in the
perception of the threat coming from
Russia in the Baltic states it seems
very tangible here in Germany it seems a
bit further away how do you explain this
uh well uh
um although Berlin and Thailand are
quite a similar distance from uh from
Kiev from that perspective to put but
true is that we are a neighboring
country to Russia we are in that context
indeed as a certain Cape of of NATO
and Madrid the particular set of
decisions about the new level of uh
Allied defense
should be implemented we have got
additional forces from allies where we
are grateful for that much needs to be
more done we would like to see a
permanent
permanent
troops on our soil and but what is very
important is that
[Music]
um
if I I just read the curvature memoirs
and I I remember the late korbachev
period from the Cold War times and it
could be asked whether a world or the
security situation in Europe was then
more peaceful than it is now and my
answer is surely it was then more
peaceful or at least more uh
expectable from the security or
predictable and now the time has changed
but also looking for example the amount
of U.S troops in Europe
in gorbach's late coverage of time it
was 300 000 U.S soldiers now even with
the added value from the U.S troops we
have one hundred thousand and so I do
feel a certain strong deficit also uh to
be honest uh you know European and not
it is not even particularly one or
another state or country but
particularly also the European continent
so we have to understand that this war
is is morally about us
uh but also it is about the outcome of
that war we'll decide also the European
new security structure because current
one is not functional in that sense that
there is a war going and the Europeans
have relied on the Americans essentially
to provide for the continent security
for a long time and now lots of
politicians are beginning to argue we
need to become more Sovereign we need to
also strengthen our own defense and in
this context ministers have just signed
and governments have signed the European
Sky Shield initiative now in the short
term this is not going to improve
estonias or Europe's protection against
the Russian threat but do you expect the
Russian threat to continue for so long
that it warrants such an investment that
is going to take years to implement to
create and sort of an Iron Dome over
Europe
well I'm not making a
politically uncorrect call for regime
change in Russia but let me state that
nobody no nation in Europe can sleep by
at night in peace when put in regime is
in Kremlin in power
so this about the Investments to defense
in Long perspective and smaller
perspective I think
surely we need to think like in a more
or economical approach about the
security but now the central point of
gravity is indeed how to win how to
support Ukraine to win this war because
without our
uh Stronger support
economically military equipment
and more pain on Russia by sanctions
Ukraine can't survive consistently this
is a issue we have to understand we can
say that okay we give one donation and
not now we are looking on our news
program another news no it is our moral
duty if uh
Ukraine is getting losses it is our
undone work and with that responsibility
we go in the morning to work and doing
whatever in our continent where bombs
are not dropped to the Kindergartens
would you like to see Vladimir Putin go
to jail
[Music]
um
now there are reports I have to ask you
about that as well that Estonia has been
Turning Away Ukrainian refugees who have
been trying to get into Estonia via
Russia
now this is of course as you know not in
accordance with their rights to ask for
Asylum regardless of where people are
from and where they've come from how do
you justify this measure
well
there are has been we have Estonia has
received
many Russian citizens now we have
together with our land border countries
put a clear set of restrictions that we
are only on the particular circumstances
letting Russian Federation citizens in
uh
dominantly
visiting near relatives humanitarian
course of course these people who belong
to the Civic resistance against Putin
um and surely we are making also on
borders security checking so uh and also
we are making passing also through in
our Eastern board and security check on
on Ukrainian uh people citizens so we
have now received a student population
is about 1.3 million we have received
around more than 100
000 Ukrainian citizens we have refused
maybe uh one percent of that amount and
the reason is that there is something
wrong that they do not
apply to these clear circumstances of
being refugees coming from Ukraine there
might be people who have resided in
Russia already far before the fall of
the stage of war or something which is
uh might rise security concerns so but
all these cases are are handled of
course in a humanistic
speedy and uh individual decision based
manner
so what do Ukrainian refugees need to
prove in order to be let in to Estonia
if there are true Ukrainian refugees
just give the objective information on
the uh on the uh course
uh all the if they have any information
to give information if they have
document documents and there will be let
in if there is a problems which might
rise and in this security particular
security the context that we are
cooperating also if you Ukrainian
officials in that matter we have to
admit that well there is a strategic
adversary from where people are coming
and surely we we have to pass particular
procedures in that context
there is now in the Baltic Sea there
have been explosions we have seen also
already before the fall of this stage of
War rather dramatic Terror acts
assassinations in Germany well
radioactive agent to use in UK
detonation by their Russian operatives
of of explosive
barracks in in Czech Republic so these
things have happened also
on by committed by undercover Russian
agents who have used uh well Force
identities in tourist visas
so is Germany naive when they say
we are going to apply strict Security
checks but essentially we are going to
let everybody in who's escaping the war
um
we are I think there is now it rises
equation what means uh the one thing is
escaping the war
Estonian pledge has been that we have to
close borders of Europe Just Pizza
people who are in a on a on their own
going to tourist uh attractions to see
prodible Gates or or Italian Old Town or
who would like because they can't buy
any more a PlayStation consoles in
Moscow because of our sanctions or they
now they are coming to Berlin or Tallinn
and want to buy from their consoles and
then return so this is I think we have
to understand that
the sanctions what we have
created have aim and the aiming is very
clear of course we need to get a
game change in Russia happening and they
should be have holistic approach to
sanctions and of course so they have to
rise the heat also in Russian Society
wake up don't walk in in Saint
Petersburg or Moscow streets Eyes Wide
Shut as nothing has happened something
has happened it literally with your tax
money or
the genocide is committed or against
well uh
one independent nation in Europe
how worried are you that Putin is going
to cross red lines and either use
nuclear force or cross-intenated
territory
I think there are different angles to
answer to that the first angle is that
speaking about the
large-scale invasion in our Direction it
means in Baltic Sea Direction
the main portion of combat forces Putin
has took and transported to Ukrainian
front so this is a tactical response but
surely I think all Europeans should be
worried about the security
environment and unpredictability of
Putin now speaking about the nuclear
threat I think Putin Putin intense to
take us in this East chicken game by
Fair the project Fair he is I think is
the core of his escalation from the
Autumn Fall and the target of that are
not ukrainians
but the Western capitals and in that
context I would say we should remember
our
parents generation from Cold War how
they survived the nuclear uh nuclear
deterrence Bush coming from coming from
Soviet Union
and I think the nuclear
deterrence needs also first you can't
fair if you fair you you lose already by
unfortunately to use the word cane
Theory because you can't put then your
if you're going backpack on nuclear
threat where you're putting it Baltic
countries Berlin Paris Washington
because and otherwise all over the
planet Russia has also bombers carrying
a nuclear weapons or submarines so in
nuclear deterrence answer is very clear
that there's a conventional war going on
and one thing
Russia is using
nuclear weapons
or nuclear Terror against Civic nuclear
objects what are several in Ukrainian
soil then the response will be
uh will be very fatal in that context
and that this has been stated by White
House the European leader have stated
what it is well this is ambivalency in
Kremlin they have to work out but I
think uh this is not the moment that we
should say that in that perspective
Putin will use nuclear weapons but
surely there is also uh of course
we have to admit also that as I remember
even Stalin didn't threat directly with
nuclear weapons as Putin is doing well
Stalin had a more ambivalent discussion
about world peace and about socialist
ideals we carried out with a nuclear uh
might but but surely this is uh we have
to understand that
our
posture for our mistake as Western
Community mistake has been strategically
that we have taken
all these
actions of Russia against West as a
separate
elements a set of separate elements
either these have been Wars however
these have been Terror actions or
interferences to elections or economic
or political corruption or infopes no
this is a one grand set to get Supremacy
superiority over West
and now uh and still Putin has not had
hidden the intent he believes he can by
putting all in uh to work it out still
and the only response
what he is afraid or he can't in a way
like stabilize is our determination and
political will now he is investing that
we will break
and the answer is I'm sure we will not
I hope to be sure
now Putin is hoping that we will break
but he's certainly hoping that Ukraine's
morale is going to break
with his
um attacks on cities like Eve Etc I've
spoken many ukrainians I've now made
over six visits to Ukraine are
and also most by weeks also during the
Spring
um
time
ukrainians Are Not Afraid even about
nuclear attack they well I can't say
that they are laughing but they are
saying that
the context is for Ukrainian perspective
they
have seen what means a peace
living on the Putin regime and so Putin
has given marvelous examples of that
that basically it means what they uh
physical Annihilation and
humiliation of human dignity it has been
against just uh
ordinary civilians
living under the occupation territory
but can I just ask about this latest
um new tactic where we're seeing the use
of drones we're seeing the use of those
one use drones essentially that explode
in cities
there is some evidence that these are
supplied by Iran now Iran denies those
but do you have evidence that Iran is
behind supplying these drones or
possibly even Rockets to Russia and how
much of a game changer is this tactic
I don't know I I hope not the game
changed in uh like a military uh meaning
but this is a question of military
experts in that context
I believe that it is in this case it is
strategically very important that
European Union the West will give a
clear response to Iran
that it is not the case where you are
autocracy or whatever country and you
think you will get any kind of uh
whatever our political investment
benefit or economic benefit by becoming
either
either
indirect or direct
accomplice in that war by supporting
military means so this is something
I in Luxembourg in foreign ministers
meeting strongly supported also idea of
sponsoring immediately the Restriction
measures uh on on these uh on this
matter
speaking about do I personally uh
have seen these drones transported from
Tehran to Ukraine also is negative but
in these cases we on the attribution we
have to rely on our partners
and
also on Monday very clearly
Ukrainian foreign minister stated that
their attribution is their Iran drones
and in that context I think of course
European Union countries now discuss
look the evidence things but I think
this is a moment we need act immediately
I'd just like to finish by asking one
question about the sanctions that the EU
agreed on against the morality police of
Iran also this week now critics are
saying this is not enough and it is
targeting people who essentially don't
travel to Europe anyway the mullahs
shouldn't the EU
impose strictum measures and
stop the nuclear deal discussions as
critics are suggesting
I would not put this drone sanctions
into the context of nuclear deal I think
now it is if I want to be very practical
if there is a case and and also to deter
other possible uh States part is to take
part of such kind of uh uh
Adventures we need to to act immediately
and with the very deterrent
and clear response
so
I think
a certain
I would be open to all uh old thoughts
European Union has had a solid and
consistent position in nuclear deal
but also to improve sanctions regime on
this
actions which take place or take place
in Iran I think I would not put to the
to the particular to the context of
nuclear deal but to keep the doors open
to make further steps also on sanction
on restrictive measures yes
foreign minister thank you very much
thank you